Ooooooh!
We met up with
Zach King
Challenged him to do
10 of our favorite
Table tennis tricks
For those of you who haven't heard of Zach
He's making the craziest magic tricks and illusions
For over 100 million followers
You should definitely check him out!
Each trick that we do
Gets harder and harder!
For the last trick
I've got my own little illusion
Is that cool?
Stay until the end!
We are gonna try and get as many shots
in 10 seconds as possible!
Let's go for 20!
Oh boy...
I think that was good!
Alright that was trick shot 1
But they get way harder!
They get way more difficult!
Knock down the rackets!
I think we can get it in 3 tries
I brought my friend Aaron from Aaron's Animals
We're ready!
Okay!
Three tries!
Oooh!
It was right there!
Aaron do you wanna join Pongfinity?
You guys have an opening?
There it is baby!
There we go!
It's the buddy shot!
I'll give you as much topspin as I can
Which is going to be A LOT of topspin!
Okay!
It just goes down!
Yea, it's because of the topspin
Oooh!
Closer!
Oooooh!
There we go!
That's wild!
They are getting harder if you didn't notice!
Yea!
A ghost serve?
What's a ghost serve?
From here...
Oh...
Then you get it!
Okay
Oooh
Yea, yea!
A little more spin!
That's it!
Oh!
Ooooooh!
Okay
Oooooh!
There we go!
That is how you do the ghost serve everybody!
Make sure to subscribe to Zach's channel
To learn that!
To learn all of the trick shots!
Around the net!
I'm ready, around the net!
Oooh!
That's deadly!
I'm gonna spin it around the net
I can't wait to see it!
More forward
That's closer!
Then let it go lower
- Little lower, yea!
Ooooh!
There it is!
That's around the net!
We finally got it!
Around the net, okay
You have to roll through with a skate board
And hit a shot on
Okay
Nope...
Wow, we got it!
50 attempts later!
They are only getting harder from here!
If I receive the serve I get a Sensei t-shirt?
Yea
Yes!
Also I noticed these are called the Sensei?
If you guys haven't picked these up on the merch store
You definitely gotta do it!
What is going on here?
I'm not going to be able to return it
I didn't even see you hit that!
I'm so confused
It's so hard!
That was an easy serve...
That was an easy serve?
Oh!
Oh there it is!
Alright this is the next trick shot!
So this was your first viral trick shot?
You just put this one shot up on the Internet
and it blew up?
Exactly! That's how it pretty much started for us
It's an honor
To be carrying on the legacy!
Oooh!
It was right there!
- You flicked it!
Oooh, it touched the flame!
Oooh?
There it is!
No way!?
Ooooh!
You'd usually want it to pass through though, huh?
Incredible!
-Wow!
Good job man!
- Way to go!
For you guys!
Pongfinity!
This is the last shot
Before my illusion trick shot!
I'm gonna serve a serve that spins around to that side
And you have to hit the moving ball
How does it sound?
That sounds 20 times more difficult
than what me and Aaron were doing!
It should be!
It's level 9!
This level is no joke!
Oooh!
Oooooohhh!!
We got it!
Wow!
- Nice!
That was incredible skill and accuracy
On both our parts
My part mostly luck!
Incredible Zach!
That was exciting!
That was good!
Alright, this next one
I got a trick for you guys
We are just going to play a regular game of table tennis!
Sounds easy?
Yea, here we go!
That was probably one of the most confusing things
we have been part of
It was pretty wild, huh?
That was crazy!
Remember to check out Zach's YouTube channel
In the links below!
Until next time!
Where did he go?